("'t Ain't Nobody's Business If I Do")
(crowd cheering)
♪ There ain't nothin I can't do ♪
♪ Or nothin' I can't say ♪
♪ That folks don't criticize me ♪
♪ But I'm going to do ♪
♪ Just as I want to anyway ♪
♪ And don't care just what people say ♪
(door creaking)
(Don sighing)
(can clanking)
(door slamming)
(hoes scraping)
(gentle music)
(hood slamming)
(trunk slamming)
(gentle music)
(door slamming)
(sign dinging)
- Wait.
(LeBron screaming)
- I guess he fell for it.
(cartoonish music)
(LeBron screaming)
- [Rick] Here's looking at you kid.
("Harry Potter Theme Song")
- [LeBron] No no no no.
What is happening?
- [Wicked Witch Of The West]
I'll get you my pretty.
(LeBron screaming)
- [LeBron] No no no no no no.
(cartoonish music)
(LeBron screaming)
(intense music)
- Hi everyone, and
welcome to the Academy's
Visiting Artists Film Series,
FilmAid Edition for Film Composers.
I'm Taura Stinson,
and today I have the
pleasure of interviewing
the amazing Kris Bowers.
- Hi Taura, good to see you.
- Good to see you, Kris.
- Yeah, thanks so much.
- Oh, thank you.
This is amazing moment.
I'm happy to...
I have so many questions for
you, but so does everyone else,
so I have to get in line?
(both laughing)
I'm just gonna jump right in.
I know that, like a
dream of mine growing up,
was to go to Juilliard,
but you actually went there.
(both laughing)
And that's amazing.
I know...
I just wanna know a little bit about that.
You don't just wake up and
decide to go to Juilliard.
So this must have been a dream
that was brewing inside of you for years.
Can you tell us a little bit about that?
- Yeah, you know, it's interesting.
I didn't actually decide that
I wanted to go to Juilliard
until I had gotten past the
first round of auditions.
My parents decided before I was born,
they wanted me to play piano,
and they-
- Oh wow.
- They really did a lot to
make sure that they put me
in the best environments
for music education,
and they drove all over LA
to find the best teachers
and all this stuff, and I was
studying piano from the
time I was four up until
all through high school.
And so I knew I wanted
to go to a conservatory,
but when I was a junior, I
had gotten a full scholarship
to Berkeley College of Music in Boston,
and I told my parents,
"That's where I'm going,
"and there's no conversation
about it," essentially.
And they were concerned
that it didn't feel like
the best structure in their mind
as far as a school environment,
and they wanted me to
consider maybe going to USC
or going to another school
where I could major in music,
but I could maybe minor in something else
or get like a general
education at the same time.
And the idea of the conservatory
was kind of making them nervous.
And it was actually a teacher of mine
and a mentor named Eric Reed,
this amazing jazz pianist,
who suggested to me and to my parents
that I should look at Juilliard,
and that it was a really great program,
and it also would provide that structure
that my parents were looking for.
And so I did the first
audition and I was kind of
not really that interested, to be honest,
and then I hadn't really
looked at the program.
And after I got through
that first audition process,
I just looked deeper into the
program and realized that,
oh, if I get in I'm one
of four jazz pianists
in the program.
And so the chances of me
studying with Kenny Barron
or Eric Reed or whomever
I wanna study with
is much higher than if I go to Berkeley,
and I'm one of hundreds of pianists.
And if I wanna study
with my favorite teacher,
that might take me a
few years to get there.
So the idea of how small
that environment was
and how familiar it was,
especially because they had a process
where they only accepted what
they lost the previous year.
And so it was a really
big mix of years and ages.
So my freshman year when I got there,
the ensemble that I was in, it was like,
me as a freshman and
then a couple of seniors
and a couple of masters students.
So it immediately puts
you in this position
where you have to
operate on the same level
as all these other players
who are older than you,
or more experienced,
and so once I understood
the program a bit more,
then that became like the
only school I wanted to go to.
And so I just really lucked out that
in that second part of
the audition process
I ended up getting in.
- Wow, that is incredible.
Way to go, mom and dad.
- Yeah.
- For that foresight.
So, you studied jazz there?
- Yeah, yeah.
- So,
I wanna know about the transition
from jazz to film scoring.
Did you always wanna score film?
Or did you wanna be a big jazz artist?
Or what was your dream?
And are you living your dream?
There's so many parts of this question.
- Yeah, my parents, like I mentioned,
as far as their plan for me,
were very serious about me
also having a plan for myself.
They asked me when I was like,
when I was a freshman in
high school, my dad was like,
"Okay, well, what's the plan for college?
"What do you think you wanna do?
"And what's the trajectory?"
Essentially.
And at that time,
I had really fallen in
love with film music,
just because my dad was
a writer for film and TV,
and so movies were just like,
something that we gathered around.
He always wanted to show
us his favorite films.
Anytime a new movie came out,
we were immediately there at the theater
to see that movie that weekend.
And up until that point,
piano had been this medium
of expression for me.
Like once I started learning
jazz and improvisation,
the thing that made me want
to continue to play piano
and make it my thing was the fact that
it felt like a safe space
for me to express emotion.
And so once I recognized
that there was a job
where I literally could
translate emotion into music,
realizing that I could listen to the score
from "Jurassic Park" and feel
the same level of adventure
and excitement that I did
when I was watching the movie,
I just told my parents,
when my dad had that conversation with me,
when I was like 12, I was like,
"I wanna go to college for jazz piano,
"and then I wanna tour with
my favorite jazz artist.
"Then I wanna tour with my own jazz band,
"and then transition into film scoring."
And I honestly, like when
I told him that plan,
I was like, yeah, so maybe
by the time I'm like 40,
I'll be getting into
film scoring essentially.
(both laughing)
It was just a combination
of the fact that I,
one, I think the touring life was just...
I mean, you know how it is.
(voices muffling)
Yeah, like the first few years I was like,
I can't do this for like 15, 20 years.
And also what was interesting
is that some of my first projects came
from people who heard me talk about that
from that young age.
Like I scored a documentary
about Kobe Bryant
that was one of my first projects,
and that came because a friend of mine
who I was in a high school
all star jazz band with
came to me at a show
here in LA with my band,
and we hadn't seen each
other since high school,
and he was like, "Man,
I remember when we were
"in that band in high school
"you mentioned wanting
to be a film composer,
"and I'm producing this
documentary about Kobe,
"and I love your music,
"and I feel like you'd be
great to compose for it."
And-
- Wow.
- So I feel like a lot of
those first opportunities
really just came because I
talked about that plan so much
that as soon as somebody
thought, oh, I need a composer,
and recognized that I wanted to do that,
they just kind of helped me
with that transition, essentially.
One other the funny thing,
which is like a slight connection for us,
is I know you obviously were nominated
for "Mudbound" and with Dee Reese,
the first time that that happened,
where somebody was like,
"Oh, you wanna be a composer,
"help me out," was Dee
Reese's first short film,
or a short film of hers
when I was in high school.
- Oh, wow.
- I didn't even know how I met her,
but she asked me if I
would score that film.
And I was like, "Yeah, I
want to," and I got home,
and I was like, I have no idea what to do.
I put the VHS in my VHS
player, and I was like,
what do I do now?
(both laughing)
- Wow.
- I told her like, "I'm sorry,
I can't score your film."
And then she became Dee
Reese, and I was like, oh man.
(voice muffling)
- Dee Reese, that's amazing.
And you know what,
we're gonna have to shorten
that six degrees of separation
and work together one of these days.
- Yeah, for sure.
- That's amazing.
Yeah, and that year I
remember meeting Kobe,
and just like, huh.
(voice muffling)
Icon.
How was it working with him?
- Man, yeah, it was amazing.
I mean, he actually has had a
huge impact on my mentality,
my life, my approach to film scoring.
So I worked with him on that documentary,
but also, one, with that documentary,
what was interesting is that
when I was brought on
the director was like,
we're pretty much done.
We have a rough cut.
We're gonna show it to Kobe.
And then we'll just
kinda edit it together,
and then make the final edits,
and then add the music, and we'll be done.
And they showed it to
Kobe, and Kobe was like,
"This is unacceptable,"
and made them start over
from scratch, essentially.
And I was already-
- He has that...
- Yeah, exactly that Mamba mentality.
And I was already on the team,
and so he just included me in the process
of building this film from the ground up.
And so I saw them put it together
and saw him kind of guiding that process
and learning about film along the way,
and so I was learning a lot
at the same time watching him,
but he would often...
One of the things he told
me that still sticks with me
in our first meeting was that,
he was like, "Watch this film
"and look at all these
experiences in my life,
"but think about emotional
moments in your own life
"that are parallel to these things for me
"and write from that place,
"from your personal, emotional place,
"and it's gonna be great, and..."
- Wait, that was his advice to you?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Wow, like, wow.
- Yeah.
- That's incredible.
- And he was always pushing me
to write the best music possible,
and then I ended up working on,
he wrote these children's books,
and I scored the audiobooks for those,
and working on his documentary
about his final season.
So I actually had a conversation with him
literally a week before he passed,
'cause we were still workin'
together on projects.
But he was constantly
helping me think about
how I could approach my craft
in the best way possible
and from different ways.
And it also helps that he
is a huge John Williams fan,
and actually used to call John Williams
a couple times a year,
like a few times a year, they would just-
- Wow.
Chat about process.
- So yeah.
- Oh, just icon to icon,
"Hello."
- Right.
(both laughing)
It's like, I wish I could (voice muffling)
just listening to those conversations.
- Wow, that is incredible.
So Kobe also had this
huge impact on children
and like a service, I feel like,
maybe connected to his daughter,
and just wanting to,
I feel like he, would've mentored,
as he was mentoring you.
In this program, we have
these children from Kenya,
and now you have a chance
to give some advice
and answer some questions,
and actually, I know there's
a lot of dreamers that have,
'cause I look at these questions,
and these are kids that
know what they want
and they just need to
know how to get there.
And so I have so many questions.
I don't wanna be unfair.
So I wanna make sure that
we get to the questions
from the kids in Kenya.
And,
so, the first question is,
"At what phase of the filmmaking process
"do you like to come to a project?"
- That's a great question.
I feel like, for me,
it's as early as possible
so that I can get a clear
understanding of the story.
It's also really...
The story and the characters.
And it's really interesting
to see how that continues
to develop over time,
because there are times
where they start to hone in
on specific themes,
or as they're working
on the edit of a film,
I start to realize, oh,
some of these other
pieces are falling away,
because they're not as important.
Or, they're trying to figure out
what the heart of the movie is,
as they're working on it,
and so if I'm along the
ride in that process,
I can kind of see what the music
should be really pointing
to with that as well.
So I feel like the earlier the better,
just because we can have
a lot of conversations
about what they're wanting
the music to really underline
and emphasize in the storytelling
and in the experience
with these characters.
But also I feel like it allows
for that trial and error period,
because if I come in too late,
really we're just trying to get it right,
and if you don't have that
much time to get it right,
it's like you're oftentimes
doing something that's somewhat expected
or doing something that comes easy.
You're trying to just get it done quickly,
but it's hard to do things
that are out of the box
if you don't have that much time.
And I love when I have
a lot of time early on
to try things and fail,
and directors that really
encourage me to really experiment,
and if we don't get it right
with that experimentation, that's okay,
'cause that experimentation
might lead us down
somewhere else and all that.
So having time to have that
sandbox period, for me,
is really important.
So earlier the better.
- Yeah, I agree.
And this question,
I think this person probably
already has a job in film,
because they wanna-
(both laughing)
"Directors might get to
attached to temp music."
I call it tempitis.
- Yep.
(both laughing)
Tempitis, yeah.
And they, so,
"The temp music that
they use during the edit,
"how do you introduce
something new to them?"
- Yeah, I mean, this person already knows.
(both laughing)
What it is.
For those of you that don't know,
temp music is the temporary music
that's being put in as they're editing
and trying to figure out what
the sound of the movie is,
and they take music from other
films and put it in there.
And for me, I feel like,
a lot of that's a
conversation with the director
to earn that trust,
because really the temp
has created this safety
where they know that this music
is hitting the emotion
that they wanna hit,
and if I can try and have
conversations with them
that can unlock what it is
that they like about it,
now there's some directors
that it's difficult,
because they're, maybe,
struggling with how to
have that conversation.
So for them it's like, "I like the temp,
"whatever you gotta do to
make it feel like that."
And that becomes a more difficult job.
And for me, when I'm put in that position,
I maybe do that process myself,
where I'm looking at what
maybe is most effective
about this temp?
Is it the instrumentation?
Is it the pace?
Is it certain moments that it's hitting?
Is it the key and the frequency?
Or is it any of those kinds of things
that might be worth
borrowing from the temp
to then build my own thing?
But any director that's
able to have a conversation
about why is this temp
making you feel that way?
I've worked a lot with Ava,
and when we talk about
temp it's really amazing,
because she talks about
the emotion behind it,
where she'll say,
"This temp is making me feel
this way in these moments,"
and so that way I know that
as long as I hit these moments
in a similar way emotionally,
it doesn't even have to be
the same instrumentation
or any of that or
borrowing too much from it,
but if we can understand
why it's hitting those beats
and how it's making her feel,
then I can kind of deduce
what might be doing that
and try my own version of that.
- That's very helpful.
'Cause sometimes it's just like,
"Oh yeah, well I just
want, here's Beyonce,
"and this is just what,
for me as a songwriter,
"and I don't know why."
And so having those,
asking those questions makes
it easier for me to say,
"Well, what is it that you got from this?
"How does it make you feel?
"Is there a lyric?
"Is the key?
"Is it the emotions, the
way she's singing it?"
So that's, yeah, I totally agree.
- Never thought about the fact
that there's temp with songs.
I didn't even think about that.
- Oh God.
And sometimes, especially because
the kinds of songs that I write,
there's usually like one song
that they use all the time,
and I'll tell you off camera because...
(both laughing)
But I'm like, oh, okay, here we go.
And I'm like, I know this
emotion, so I don't know.
I guess it's a good thing.
- Yeah, yeah, they know you can hit it-
(voice muffling)
- Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
So, what's the most creative technique
you've been able to bring to
your film career and process?
- That's a really good question.
I feel like for me,
it's my background as an
improviser and as an accompanist,
just because the thing
I've always loved about
being a jazz pianist is that
you operate in these two spaces
where sometimes you're the lead performer,
especially if you have a trio
or you're playing solo piano,
but most often you're an accompanist,
where you're tryin' to figure out
how to make these harmonies
support the singer
or support the horn player, whatever.
And especially when those
people are improvising,
you're tryin' to figure out
how to fill in the holes
or how to do something that's
gonna make what they're doing
make sense or contextualize
what's happening.
And so for me,
I approach film scoring the same way
where I'll watch a scene
over and over again
without anything,
and often try to figure
out what the emotion is
that we're trying to get at
based on the conversation
with the director
and based on what I'm seeing.
And then I go to the piano and improvise
and to try to find
something that feels like it
is getting me to a similar emotion.
And then I just kind of
play along to the screen
as if I'm accompanying something,
but it's nice to be able to move around
and not have to think about,
and not have to write something out.
Like I can sit behind a
scene over and over again
and just try a bunch of different things
and try a bunch of
different chord changes.
And then I'm also thinking
in that accompanist way,
where there might be
moments where I'm like,
oh, I wanna leave a hole for that line,
or I wanna emphasize that line,
or I wanna make a shift under that line.
And I'm really treating
it like the dialogue
and the sound is another
set of instruments
that I'm playing behind.
And that improvisation
also is incredibly helpful
in this crazy industry, as you know,
of people changing their
minds at the last minute
where there were times
at a recording session
where a director is like,
you know what, I actually
never really liked that moment.
Can we try something else?
- Right.
- Oh yeah, that's easy.
- Yeah, sure, yeah.
(voice muffling)
- Yeah.
(both laughing)
- Nothin' like being able to
make those changes quickly
and not have to worry too much
and just being able to trust my instincts
on improvisation have been
really, really valuable, yeah.
- Yeah, agreed.
So this...
I had this question as well.
Someone asked, "When did you realize
"that you'd like to apply
your classical training
"to a film career?"
'Cause one of my,
what I noticed is that your,
over time your scores have
become a bit more classical.
And so, yeah, so I wanted
to ask that question, too.
- Yeah, I appreciate that.
I think that it's something
I've always dreamt about
because the film music
I fell in love with,
even at the same time
as I was falling in love
with all the jazz records
I was falling in love with,
like Oscar Peterson or Wynton Kelly
or Miles Davis, Herbie Hancock,
I was also listening
mostly to John Williams
or Howard Shore or James Newton Howard,
or like these composers that
I definitely had also a
huge love and soft spot
for Terence Blanchard
and composers that were using
jazz elements in their scores.
But when I thought of film scoring,
I thought of John Williams
or I thought of these movies
that were shaping my childhood.
And so I always dreamt of
trying to get more into
that type of space,
and as you were just kind of saying,
it's really interesting to kinda navigate
when you're known for something,
when people come to you for that thing,
and I remember my first
couple of projects, it was,
I was just very fortunate
to have directors
that took a chance on
me doing something else,
because I remember my first few meetings,
I would go into a studio meeting,
and those studio heads would be like,
oh, we don't really have
any jazz stuff or any-
- Oh, wow, yeah.
- Yeah or they'd send me-
(voice muffling)
Hip hop stuff just because
that seemed like it probably made sense.
(both laughing)
And it was,
that Kobe Bryant documentary
is because my friend was like,
"You're a dope musician,
"and I know that if I give
you context and temp music
"and we talk about Cliff Martinez
"or Philip Glass or Steve
Reich or that kind of music,
"that you're gonna be able to get that,
"or (voice muffling)."
Justin Simien, even though a
lot of that has jazz in it,
he was also like,
"I want jazz, but I also want Ravel,
"or I want things that feel like Chopin
"or like that kind of material."
So I feel like a lot of
that was really helpful
in giving me the experience
of writing that way.
And same with Kobe, actually.
Kobe, for his audiobooks,
John Williams was always
his template in his mind
of what score would sound like.
And so, the stuff I had
to write for that was
trying my best to write that Harry Potter
type of style of writing,
which for me just meant
studying those scores
and studying how to write in that style.
So I feel like by the time something like
"Bridgerton" came along, which is like
completely this classical sound.
A lot of it was like a combination
of me always wanting to do that,
also having filmmakers that gave me
the space and trust to do that,
just because, like "Bridgerton" came along
because I had done a Shondaland
show a few years ago,
that sounds nothing like that,
and they just, again, trusted
that as a good musician,
I might be able to figure that sound out.
And for me, it was all
about studying that.
By the time I got "Bridgerton"
I had done so much studying that I felt
much more confident and
comfortable in that kind of space.
So, I feel like it's like,
I know people, I've always
heard my whole life like that,
you've probably heard it,
that success is when
preparation meets opportunity.
- Preparation, yeah.
- Yeah, and so for me-
- Yeah, absolutely.
I'm just like, always like,
how can I continue to prepare?
Because who knows when that
opportunity's gonna come along?
- Yeah. I mean, if you (laughing)
I am positive that
Shonda Rhimes could see,
I feel like she's this person that,
'cause she's all knowing and all seeing,
she could see-
(Kris laughing)
So she saw that in you and knew that,
and gave you that opportunity.
'Cause oftentimes we go into
meetings, like you said,
and this, "Oh, can you
write this hip hop song?"
Or can you...
I love that when people take chances,
and that's how we blossom,
that's how we grow.
That's how we get to just stretch.
I love that.
So, what questions do you ask yourself
that help you to decide
the style of score you'll be creating?
- Well, I guess if it's
on a specific project,
most of that is dictated by
conversations with the director.
Like, oftentimes it's
talking to him or her
about what they might envision
in terms of what this character listens to
or what kind of music is
happening in this environment,
or if there's any music,
oftentimes directors I work with
were listening to music
when they were writing,
if they were also the
writer of the script.
So I often ask,
"What other stuff have
you been listening to?"
That's really helpful.
I also really love
creating these boundaries
that I can then play in where,
for a movie like "King Richard,"
I thought about the fact that
it might be interesting to pull elements
from this world sonically,
thinking about the sound of tennis
and the sound of the
ball hitting the strings
and things like that.
- [Taura] Mmm, yeah.
(voice muffling)
- Prepared piano or all these other things
that kind of maybe would
create a nice texture
that made sense for me with the film.
- Yes, so when you,
when we are talking
about the kinds of films,
the sound that you're developing is,
is moving into classical.
It is classical.
So when you, will you score other films
that will take you completely out of that?
You know how John Williams has a sound.
Are you creating that Kris Bower sound?
- I don't know.
I think, I often look at,
John Williams, I've
studied his career a lot,
and I think the thing that
was really fascinating for him
is when he was around my age and in his,
I'd say, like 20s to 30s,
he was doing a lot of studio work
where he was just kind of writing
the style of these different people.
And I think also at the time there was,
you saw this old Hollywood
style of orchestral writing
and things like that.
But within that, he was writing
all these different versions of it
and really trying to write
different types of music.
So I feel like I'm kind of
in that period of my life
where I'm just open to,
whatever's going to challenge me.
I think, again, something
else that Kobe mentioned
to me a lot was like,
before you say yes to something,
think about how that's
going to challenge you
and make you a better
composer by the end of it.
And if you feel like that's
gonna do that, then take it.
And so oftentimes, even projects that are,
often projects that my team is like,
why are you doing that?
(voice muffling)
I wanna do it because
it's gonna gimme a chance
to exercise this muscle
that I've never had.
Like before scoring "Space Jam,"
I wanted to score raising "Raising Dion"
'cause I'd never done something
that demanded a bigger
sound or an action sound.
And so for me it was just,
what's gonna make me better?
And how can I take those
things on to continue to grow?
So maybe at some point
I'll have a sound that's identifiable,
but I feel like right now it's just,
I'm still in student mode.
- Developing.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's amazing that you feel that way.
(both laughing)
'Cause you are...
I hear...
I don't know how I missed
that you did "Raising Dion."
I just, I binge watched it yesterday.
- Oh thank you.
- I mean, two days, two seasons.
- Wow, oh wow, that's amazing.
- I had to check out and just recenter,
and I did it with "Raising Dion."
So sidebar.
(both laughing)
- Appreciate it.
- That's amazing.
I love that kid.
It's just like such a cool...
I really love it.
So my next question is
"What's the one film score
that gets stuck in your head?"
- I mean there's definitely a lot.
I mean,
they're cliche just 'cause
they are what they are.
I feel like "Jurassic
Park" and "Star Wars"
are probably two that
really stick in my mind,
just because they're,
yeah, just-
- Yeah,
- Listened to them so
much when I was a kid,
and they were such big
part of my childhood,
and I feel like for all of us,
it's such a nostalgic feeling
that you get immediately
when you hear any of
those chords or harmonies.
And also "E.T."
- "E.T." Yes.
- The piano theme, the
flying theme from "E.T."
is like something that sticks with me.
So yeah, John Williams is always my go to.
- Yes, mine, too.
I loved...
When I was a kid,
I wanted to date two
people when I grew up,
and I was sure that I was gonna date E.T.
(Kris laughing)
(voice muffling)
My mom was like, "Okay girl."
(Kris laughing)
E.T. and Scooby Doo,
I'm gonna be with them when I grow up.
(voice muffling)
(Kris laughing)
(both laughing)
So obviously, I watched
a lot of movies and TV.
So my next question is
"The director has a new
idea that contradicts
"an earlier conversation
that you had with them."
How do you handle those
tricky conversations
"without compromising your
own vision for the score?"
- I think for me,
the vision is whatever serves the story.
So there's so many times where I have,
you take the time to come up
with a really clear vision for something,
and then I take it to the
director and they're like,
"No, that's not it."
And then for me I feel like
we are all trusting this director
with the vision of what this story is,
and the best directors are
also trusting the story
to be what it wants to be and to kind of,
following that as it's north star.
And so I feel like for me,
whatever the director says is what it is.
And so oftentimes a director
changing their mind,
for me, has always led me to
a much stronger
representation in the music,
in the score where like,
there are times where we're maybe
scoring a certain
character in a certain way
and we realize that we need
to be a bit more complex
or not as one dimensional
with how we're doing that.
Or by the time we get too
far along into the film,
we realize that the way we've been scoring
this relationship or this character
doesn't pay off in the way we want it to.
So now we have to go back
and try to figure that out.
And also at the end of
the day, we're all humans.
There's so many times
where I changed my mind
about life, about so
many different things,
that it's always about
us being open to that.
And I feel like allowing
for that human aspect
of people feeling differently
once they've had time
to really sit with something,
only allows for better art.
- Yeah, and taking nothing personal.
I feel like in life and film,
whenever I go into a project,
I know that if someone
says, I don't want that
or I want this temp song,
just like that, I just
don't take it personally.
And also being willing to do
as many revisions as possible,
just 'cause I know it really gets better.
Every now and again, you may,
oh, I miss the original version,
but I usually really,
really like the process
of going to doing it over
until it gets, we get it right.
- Yeah, 100%.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that's great, yeah.
- So "How do you find the
film's musical language?
"And what about the
films repeating motifs?"
- So I feel like the
motifs usually come from
once I've had those
conversations with the director
about what's most important to them,
we usually try to focus on those moments.
And for me, I'll always
watch the film through
until I find a moment that speaks to me
on a really visceral level,
where with "Green Book,"
it was this moment where
Mahershala's character,
Don Shirley, was standing outside
watching these black field workers
while he's being driven by this white man,
and you see this
solitude in his eyes,
and this almost tinge of sadness or pain.
And that was the moment that felt like,
I feel like I can
immediately write something
that maybe can get at that feeling.
And then that theme was now his theme,
and now I can look at any moment
where we wanna work with his theme
and try to put that in those other places.
Same with "King Richard."
It was like seeing this father
being told no over and over again,
and then just keeping a
brave face for his kids
and continuing to push his kids
in this positive, beautiful way.
And with that, that was a
moment that really spoke to me.
And so once I had that theme,
that was Richard's theme.
So then I go through and figure out
where else can we use Richard's theme?
And then sometimes when I
look at the other themes,
it's how does that theme then play with
the theme that has
already been established
or what are we trying to
say with that character?
And kinda do the same thing.
Thinking about something like "Space Jam."
It was this relationship
between LeBron and his son,
but also Al G., the Don Cheadle character,
was like all about ego
and toxic masculinity,
essentially, all these things.
And so, I feel like both of those worlds
are worlds that I could
easily kind of put my head,
get into that head space
and write something from that place.
And then once I have those
themes that are really strong,
it's just continuing to follow the story
with those characters or those motifs,
'cause there are even times
where that character might not be present,
but whatever we're talking
about in that scene
might have to do with that character.
And so, using that theme there,
and by the time I do that,
it often feels like a lot of the movie
has kind of been scored at that point.
And then it's about kind
of filling in the holes.
- Yeah, that's, okay.
So you just hit us with like three movies
that I know I love,
and I'm sure everyone watching does, too.
I have a two-part question, I think.
What musical story do you wanna tell?
I know with Don Shirley,
is there someone else that you,
or can you even share that, like what...
It could even be like the story
of how a city feels to you.
It doesn't have to be a
certain, you know what I mean?
Do you have a musical
story that you haven't told
that you personally wanna tell?
- Yeah, I don't...
There are definitely a lot of musicians
that I really would love to...
I'm just curious about their lives
and how to tell that story,
like thinking about Duke
Ellington or Billy Strayhorn
or Thelonious Monk or Louis Armstrong.
I feel like Louis Armstrong
is really fascinating to me,
because I mean him and Duke Ellington,
they were these icons,
and these like pop icons and celebrities
at a time where they
were also experiencing
what it was like to be a
black man in this country
in a way that I just don't know how
Louis Armstrong was able
to be as warm and uplifting
and such a beautiful spirit and energy
for the rest of the world
when he was dealing with that personally.
So I feel like those stories,
maybe as far as musicians,
immediately come to mind.
- Yeah, yeah.
I see that for you.
The other, it's a fun question,
but I don't know if you
can really answer it.
(Kris laughing)
Do you have a favorite?
Do you have a favorite
film that you've worked on?
I mean, you've worked on
TV and film, but film,
do you have a favorite score?
- You know, not really.
It's really, like you said,
it's really tough to answer that.
I think that generally
it's usually whatever is like
the last thing I worked on
kind of feels like (voice muffling)
feel most connected to and most proud of,
especially 'cause it always represents
some sort of maturation or something.
So I do think "King Richard," in that way,
is probably right now one that
really like sticks with me,
but there's always an element of each one
that I feel proud of and I'm sure
the next one's gonna be my favorite.
- And that, I'll tell you,
I went to see that movie three times.
- [Kris] Oh wow, oh man.
- I, every time,
no one was watching, and they were,
because like, oh...
Because it just pulls on you
in so many different ways,
just beautifully executed,
just beautifully written,
beautiful, all the acting,
everything was amazing,
script, everything.
So the other question is,
the last question from this series,
and we have a couple more,
"How is composing for
film similar or different
"from composing for other mediums
"like classical or jazz performances?"
- That's interesting.
I feel like,
one is the fact that the film
you are always a part of something else.
And so oftentimes there are times where
I might wanna do something
because as a musician
I really wanna kind of exercise an idea
or build something out and kind of
make something feel really big,
or whatever it might be, or busy,
and that's not gonna be the best thing
to serve the action or
the story or the moment.
And so, even though I
love being an accompanist,
as a film composer, you're always that.
And I think in the concert space,
there's nothing that you're
accompanying in that way
in terms of being able to write whatever.
And oftentimes that can be
a bit more difficult for me,
where thinking about a couple of
classical pieces I've written
in the last few years,
written a couple of concertos
and those are so difficult for me
because now every second is something,
can be something else.
And oftentimes it's really helpful
to have something that
you're accompanying.
'Cause then you're just
focusing on supporting something
instead of trying to
constantly think of how to fill the space.
But I think the similarity for me is also
always based in storytelling
and emotion where
even as a jazz pianist,
if I was improvising,
it was my turn to improvise,
for me I always had to feel like
what is my mood right now?
What's the mood of the space?
Where do I want to
improvise from emotionally?
And that just became a north star,
and anytime I didn't have that,
I just felt like I was just playing,
not connected to my heart.
It was like mostly just muscle memory
or playing from my brain.
And I feel like even when I'm
writing something for that space,
it's the same thing where I
need to have some sort of story
or idea or emotion that
I'm trying to capture,
because then I feel
like I have a north star
that I can go after instead
of just writing something
to be musically impressive or
like an exercise, essentially.
- Yeah, got it.
"So what is your favorite
musical composition?
"And what makes it so good?"
- That's a really tough question.
I think the answer I always
come to is "Lush Life,"
"Lush Life," by Billy Strayhorn, which is,
it's a really heart
wrenching, beautiful song.
My favorite recording of it
is Johnny Hartman and John Coltrane.
And it's this sad song about a guy
who lives a lush life,
like lives a life drinking,
at dive bars, and all that.
And I fell in love with the song,
and then afterward learned
that Billy Strayhorn
was 17 when he wrote it,
and learning about the
pain that he experienced
as a gay man, a gay man at that time,
a gay black man at that time.
- Wow.
- Such a heaviness
to that song, and it's still beautiful,
and it's like a through composed thing
that has a journey to it.
So I feel like "Lush Life"
is always a song that I come back to.
- Hmm, I'm gonna have to check that out.
(voices muffling)
Okay, so, "What mood is the
hardest to compose music for
"and why?"
- You know, I think the
toughest mood for me is
comedy or levity.
- Mmm, yeah.
- I find that
it's easy to be on the nose, in a way,
where it's not very interesting
or it feels very expected,
and how to make something feel funny,
but feel unique to
whatever that is is funny,
I feel like is something
that I always find difficult.
'Cause it's easy to
just kind of go through,
pull out the pizzicato strings
and whatever else might
make it (voice muffling).
This is the funny sounding music,
but to do it in a way that
makes it feel unique to that,
I think, is always something
that's a bit more of a challenge,
and isn't as immediate to me or for me
as a lot of other emotions.
- Yeah, I agree.
I did have fun with "Just Look Up."
That was a-
(voices muffling)
I think it's the world.
The world was falling apart,
and I'm like, oh, okay.
The inspiration wasn't too far.
Turn the TV on, read the newspaper.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So "what would you consider
the most challenging aspect
"of composing music?"
- I think it, for me, it's myself,
getting out of my own
way and the fact that
the whole time I'm writing music,
I'm thinking about how bad it is
or why I shouldn't be doing what I'm doing
or why I'm making a mistake or,
I think the stress of the
process, for me, most of the time,
comes from the internal
dialogue I'm having with myself
or my fears of,
you're writing this music for
somebody else to say is good.
So then it's tough to think about
whether or not what you're doing
is going to please this other person.
You can't really control that.
And that's why it's always
great to have directors
that create a safe
environment where you can feel
not so concerned about that.
But I do find that that
part of the process
does create this cycle for
me with internal dialogue,
that can be a little tough sometimes.
I feel like that's
probably the hardest part,
is just getting outta my own way.
- Yeah.
Yeah, move, Kris,
get out the way.
(both laughing)
Just sing that little song.
(voices muffling)
(both laughing)
So, "Describe a time when
a musician or director
"disagreed with you, and what happened?"
That's what they said.
They want to know what happened.
- Yeah, what happened?
Yeah, sure, I mean, it
happens most of the time.
I think that it...
Not most of the time.
Actually, that's not true.
I think it happens quite frequently.
And I feel like there might be,
maybe one time on every project
where that might happen,
where I feel like I should
go in a certain direction
and the director doesn't feel that way.
But most of the time
when I take their advice,
that ended up being the right way to go.
One very specific example
that I always find really interesting
is the very first score
that I wrote was for,
excuse me, it was a
documentary for this woman,
Elaine Stritch, who
was a Broadway actress,
and she, at the time, she's passed now,
but at the time she was still alive,
and she was dealing with diabetes
and had health issues very frequently,
and she was in and out of the hospital.
And there was a theme in the documentary
where the doctor was telling her,
she had a really bad health scare,
and the doctor was telling her
how important it was for
her to take care of herself
because of how close she
was to death, essentially.
And I wrote this piece
of music that felt like
emotional and felt like it was,
carried that level of-
- Of cautionary.
- Yeah, cautioned, yeah.
And the director was like,
this feels too sad.
This feels like she did die.
Like this feels like it's gone
too far in that direction.
And I wasn't really sure how to take that.
And so I tried a couple other things,
and then it felt like we went too far
in the other direction,
where now it didn't feel like tense enough
or didn't feel like had enough caution.
And the solution actually ended up being
changing the main instrument from piano
to a different instrument,
because it was the sound of piano
that made this moment feel
a bit, too, sensitive,
or too, emotional.
And so I feel like that was a moment
I feel really thankful to have
had so early in my career,
because that immediately
made me feel like,
oh, this instrument feels a certain way,
especially for this director.
And so now I know that
if somebody says something's too sad,
it might not be the piece of music.
It might just be this instrument.
- Yeah, that's a good note.
"Can you explain how you might
compose a new piece of work?"
- Yeah, I think-
- So do you usually sit down to a piano?
Or I know, I mean, you're a pianist,
but sometimes you pick up the guitar or...
- No, I definitely don't pick
up any other instruments.
I wish I could play another instrument.
Like me playing guitar
is a very sad sight.
it's like piano and
other various keyboards.
But other than that process
I was mentioning earlier
about improvising and (voice muffling)
trying to improvise around feeling,
oftentimes it's stepping away
from an instrument completely,
and just trying to think
about what that feels like
and honestly kind of singing to myself
or thinking about sounds in my own head
where I feel like, okay,
if I felt this way,
what does that sound like?
And oftentimes I also start thinking about
what other pieces of music
make me feel that way.
So, interesting for me to look at,
there are a couple of pieces
I know that directly influenced
John Williams, for example,
with like the sound of
this Shostakovich piece
or the sound of this other classical piece
and the emotion that it carried
and then how he was able to
totally do his own thing with that.
And so for me I feel like
I've always looked at that
as a piece of reference where,
if I'm writing something
that's supposed to feel angry,
for example, then oftentimes
if I'm stuck on where to start,
I'll also think about
what other music do I
feel makes me feel angry
or when I'm angry I wanna listen to,
'cause it makes me feel like
I can tap into that emotion
or whatever that is.
And then I go listen to that music
and see if there's something about that,
whether it's the tempo or something
with the harmonies or the
melody or something about that
that is getting at that
feeling in a very acute way.
And then I maybe try to
borrow that element of it
and then build on that.
So sometimes, like, I love this,
that video it's on YouTube and Vimeo,
like "Everything's a Remix,"
just because it talks
about how every new idea
is not a new idea.
That's all built on something else.
And so not being afraid
of looking elsewhere
for inspiration because,
thinking that you have to
reinvent the wheel every time
is where you get really stuck.
- Yeah, I have to look at that, too.
"Everything's a Remix."
I'm not familiar.
- It's dope, they literally
like do like AB images of
"Star Wars" Akira Kurosawa films,
or like "Star Wars" and
old fighter jet films,
or Quentin Tarantino and westerns,
it just kind of shows how much people
literally take frames from other movies
as far as the way they shoot something
or the way they-
- Oh, yeah.
- And all that, yeah.
So it's-
- Very cool.
Okay, last question,
"Your composition is poorly
received and has to be revised.
"What do you do?"
- Well, I feel like that was traumatic.
I was like, wait, which
composition was poorly received?
I was like...
(both laughing)
(voice muffling)
I feel like, for me,
I always try to get to,
immediately to the solution,
like the answer, like why
was it feeling that way?
'Cause there's always...
I don't really sit too long
in the disappointment of that.
I think that honestly,
my trouble with sitting in
some sort of doubtful place
happens before I even
share a piece of music,
but once I share something
and somebody tells me
that this didn't work,
often, I'm like,
like why didn't that work?
So I can figure out
what to do differently,
and asking those questions.
'Cause oftentimes it's like,
is it something about the
emotion that I'm missing?
Is it something about the pace of it?
Is it something about the instrumentation?
Is it like...
Oftentimes I'll ask a director,
if I'm really far off,
if there's another piece of music
that does get to that feeling for them
or that they can think of,
and it's been really interesting sometimes
where I'll ask a director that,
and they'll gimme a reference
that I'll listen to,
and I'm like, this doesn't
sound anything like
what we're working on,
or even sometimes,
there's sometimes a director is like,
"I think of the sound of this other piece,
"and because it has this instrumentation,"
and I listen to that piece,
and it doesn't have that
instrumentation at all.
But oftentimes, I'm like, okay,
well there's something about this
that made you feel a certain way.
And so let me look at that,
and is there anything about this
that I can borrow or figure out?
And so usually it's just asking questions,
like asking so many questions
so I can use this mistake or use this,
yeah, mistake-
- Lesson.
- Yeah, exactly, lesson.
So I can kinda figure out
how to do something different
and move in the right direction.
- Yeah, absolutely.
So any final advice for students
getting into film composing?
- Yeah, a few things.
I think,
one, always be a student
and be obsessed about craft
and getting better and learning.
And that's all aspects of this job,
because it's fascinating
how much of this job
as a film composer can be
in the technical aspect
of knowing how to use
certain pieces of software
or knowing how to
actually record the music
that you're gonna need to record
or make that music in terms
of the technical part of that.
But also, knowing how to express yourself
with technical ability,
I think is incredibly important,
because technique only allows you
to then express yourself
in a more fluid way.
And then the second thing to that
is to really tap into
what it is that you love,
because that's what makes you unique.
Like it's so interesting to me how much,
I'll never forget, some of the albums
that I found or feel like I found
and discovered that changed my life.
And then I talked to
somebody else about it,
and they're like, "Oh yeah."
And I'm like, "Wait, how are you not..."
- Exactly.
- You know?
And that kind of taught me that
the fact that that speaks to
me so deeply, so personally,
means that there's
something in there for me
to continue to discover,
figure out why that's a part of me
that I'm hearing in
that piece, essentially.
And so whenever you
recognize those moments,
really hold onto those things
and then go deeper into those things.
Yeah, I feel like those
two pieces of advice
feel like things that I always
think about myself, even.
- Yeah, great advice.
I just wanted to talk a moment
about education being key.
'Cause I know that not
everybody has access,
and when I was growing
up, I just didn't want...
Just for transparency, my
mom was a single mother,
and her best...
What she wanted to do for me
was to make sure I survived
East Oakland, California.
And so now looking back,
I have all this information,
and whenever I have an
opportunity or an audience
I like to talk directly about education
and how we have the
ticket to that freedom,
whatever we want, when we have,
we do well at school.
Can you speak to that?
- Yeah, 100%.
I feel like it's really
interesting how much,
the way that our systems have been built,
especially educational
systems have been built,
to make us feel like
if you're not excelling
that you're dumb or you're
not good at these things,
and in a way where it could
be very easy to just give up
because you kind of
accept this prescription
that the system has kind of given you,
even though a lot of these
systems have been built
to allow that failure,
and I feel like,
really it's all about being curious,
continuing to move at your own pace
and learn things at however
you wanna learn them.
And like you said, knowing that those,
the more you do that,
the more you're going to
unlock aspects of your future.
- [Taura] Absolutely.
- It's pretty fascinating to see how much
the world can change for you,
the more that you feel educated
in whatever space you
might wanna be focused in
or any of that.
And yeah, I feel like
knowing that
anything that you're
maybe feeling is difficult
and that you're failing in,
you're not a failure.
It's just something that-
- A lesson.
- Exactly, it's something
to continue to chip away at
and find the people and the environment
that's gonna help support that.
I think it's always
disappointing in spaces where
the environment that you're
in is reinforcing these ideas
that you might not achieve something.
And that's just not true.
Whenever I look at any great person
that I've either had
the fortune to be around
or have studied,
there's a book actually
that I read recently
about greatness, where it's a myth
that people are born great or
born with these crazy talents
or born with these
abilities that every person
just spent much more
time than anybody else
doing that thing.
- Absolutely.
- If you just spend time in any space
that you wanna be great at,
then you're going to be great.
And just keep-
(voices muffling)
- I totally agree.
Knowledge is power.
- Yeah.
- It truly is.
It's our way up, our way
out, our way through.
- Yeah, totally, totally agree.
- Well, Kris, this was amazing.
I love...
I could have done this
a couple of more hours,
just amazing talking to you,
and I hope to talk to you more.
- Yeah, definitely.
Hope to work with you-
- Thank you so much.
- Yeah, for sure.
- Thank you, Kris, for that
wonderful conversation.
And thank you for participating
in the Academy's Visiting
Artist Film Series,
FilmAid Edition for Film Composers,
and songwriters.